new exclusive you gov Poll for Sky News
has revealed that support for Scottish
independence has decreased this comes as
voting gets underway in a contest to
succeed Nicholas sturgeon as leader of
the Scottish national party well support
for Scottish independence has continued
to slide as this exclusive Poll for Sky
News shows 39 are now backing an exit
from the United Kingdom that's in
comparison to 47 who want to remain part
of the Union the survey also revealed
that 52 of the public believe Scotland
would still be part of the UK in 10
years time
the polling also shows the 44 think the
Scottish government is doing a good job
meanwhile 46 think the opposite
well let's bring in our Scotland
correspondent Connor giddies to talk
about this poll now and just how it
feeds into this leadership Race Connor
yeah this is not what SNP members who
are beginning to cast their votes today
will have been wanting to hear this
exclusive Sky News you gov Paul released
in the last few minutes paints a bleak
picture for the campaign for Scottish
independence suggesting that support for
Independence has dropped to 39 it gets
worse regardless of your view regardless
of the view of people who were
questioned in this poll 52 percent think
Scotland will still be part of the
United Kingdom in 10 years time again
not something that SNP members casting
those votes today will be wanting to
hear let's look though at what this poll
is suggesting when it comes to domestic
policy here in Scotland because after
all it's the candidates who are vying to
replace Nicholas sturgeon those are the
main tasks that they will have to deal
with on day one 62 of those asked say
that the smp's handling of the NHS has
been bad that is a huge blow for humza
Yusuf the current health secretary seen
by many as a front-runner in this
campaign when it comes to who's the best
first minister at 27 the highest
proportion think Cape Forbes she is
leading out on that 22 think comes a
Yusuf and then trailing well behind in
third is Ash Regan on 14 and if we dig a
little deeper into this 44 think Humsa
Yusuf is a bad leader and he also fails
on all of the indicators when it comes
to being weak incompetent and
untrustworthy Cape Forbes wins when it
comes to those now clearly this is what
the public is uh this is the tone of
what the public is feeling at the moment
but at the end of the day this is SNP
members who will have their casting vote
who will be making a decision and Hamza
Yusuf has the highest profile backers
the highest profile support within the
SMP and he will be taking much comfort
from that of course attention is very
quickly turning to what's happening here
behind me this evening the Sky News
debate live with Beth Rigby our
political editor you can see her just
over at the podium there the gloves were
well and truly Shanghai will be well and
truly coming off in this because of
exactly what this poll is suggesting
Beth will be cross-examining those
candidates testing their policies
testing their personalities and then it
will be open to the floor each of the
candidates and the podiums here will be
allowed to test one another which should
make for very interesting viewing so
that all begins here live on Sky News
this evening at seven o'clock